hey guys I am JC cariah's and I am Chris
cope a welcome to another episode of
impaired we are your co-hosts and we are
an Oreo cookie of getting [ __ ] up I'm
an alcoholic
he's a pot and what we like to do is
bring our buddies on and then what do we
do but we play a bunch of fun games we
get a bunch of people [ __ ] up and then
we have a great old time let's do it
let's bring out our guest
[Music]
the small screen you've seen her on
snowfall and dr1 people and she does all
this while making her parents very proud
from the barn fires water
[Applause]
sending a mighty 14 seeds and 11 inches
tall with hair so dirty-blond it looks
like it was kissed by the mighty Zeus
himself it appeared on The Tonight Show
recently released this gentle giant hail
from Vancouver British Columbia give it
up
I bet dirty
[Music]
hey guys what's going on welcome to
impaired here we are with our guests
Lachlan and Fez everybody welcome right
hey guys welcome to our show we're so
happy to have you on thank you for
spending your late afternoon with us
yeah and also being willing to get
intoxicated at this hour
yeah hey which is nice I feel like we're
almost there we've can't we've been kind
of pre-gaming a little bit yeah knocking
out of fun Thursday sweet all right well
first off let me go ahead and write down
the one of the games that runs the
entire length of the show it's called
secret word mm-hmm and basically the the
production team has picked up found a
word that we may use frequently but we
don't know what it is and if one of us
says it by chance we will hear the
phrase alabaster thank you here how
about sir that means the secret word has
been said and you got to stop what
you're doing and drink and or smoke and
to that I think before we get the show
started we should Cheers yeah thank you
guys what are we cheersing to each other
to each other
you guys I was solid this is backwash
but I mean not really mere backwash yeah
mines back wash your own backwash yeah
we were supposed to right cuz we she
started drinking before the camera and I
spit it back in and dude is that for
real
yeah like to have cheers again I'm gonna
tell you I'm gonna say that I did a
pretty goddamn good job with that it was
that good it was good
no that was a good shot I was very
obviously another one I feel bad I feel
bad I didn't have any well you think
line they don't know that I just thought
I don't take the heart okay drinks beer
he smokes he's he's a man
so like the last time you drank you
ended up in the shower
oh yeah clothes ended up in the shower
and you were not in the shower I walked
into the bathroom and the clothes were
in the shower and I looked up and I had
a hospital bracelet on and I had no idea
why oh my god and so and did your
girlfriend fill in the blank she did
right so what happened what were the
blanks I was an ass you know what's even
worse is there is recorded footage of Oh
wrong somewhere and I'm humiliated and
like Conan was there are the the Booker
for Coto JEP user the common central
Booker's were there why'd you get so
drunk that it was part of the show just
like this show oh so there's no
consequence right and also the Booker
from Conan probably won't be watching
this okay JP tune out now it's more than
five minutes he won't watch it good
absolutely
all right you would jump into the first
thing man the first thing we're gonna do
is called hometown harassment what we do
is is we look up fun facts or not so fun
facts about our guests hometown visit
you are from Jupiter Florida so I think
I'll start before Mars
that's so funny cuz like Florida people
when you [ __ ] on Florida no more
generating you interrupt but into the
passwords are the secret word we don't
know what I don't know what it is I mean
you gotta say it rate because it happens
through conversation organic no no he's
giving parents Sharon I thought we were
the ones who knew what it was and no he
said still no no my it's it's well no we
get it or not ah okay go ahead back to
what you were doing ah no it's funny
because like people [ __ ] on the state of
Florida but they don't realize that
inside the state of floor there is a
city hierarchy so when I said Jupiter
she's like oh [ __ ] no now and
four miners that's a bougie asked hell
feather Factory in Fort Myers Florida I
thought feathers were natural know if
you want a purple ostrich feather you
gotta go to a [ __ ] fancy [ __ ] gotta
make that so do you think that they
actually make feathers there yeah I
think that they just take feathers that
we think it's our own gas property with
birds running around though that was a
fake factory at Fort Worth at they're
just dying the feathers are preparing
them to look different for path that's
how they open every morning on the
factory floor every meeting is just a
[ __ ] of a feather now we can commence
poor birds we should say that no did I
this is something I didn't realize uh
Fort Myers over anywhere in the United
States on most days of sunshine I don't
know that was really depressed growing
up having a hard time in Florida get out
now that was yeah yeah years they're
gonna blame for that it was blaming
harassment no no no when we say the
third thing I just want to move on
because you just brought up such a bad
[ __ ] no no it's not good yeah what's bad
it's bad we're all gonna don't blame
physic for 9/11 guys nah Mike stop it
it's not her fault I was an 11th grade
in math class it's just funny though
hilarious is there one more factor you
can't move on I know because of this
9/11 debacle there's a well you know
what there's one quick thing and I don't
ask woman I know it did you know for
Myers was the first city in Florida to
have electricity but your town was a
bunch of piece of shits who hated
progress they complained because it kept
the cows up well you know it's just just
like today like some people don't know
so this whole them blaming you for 9/11
starting to make a lot of sense
yeah I really Helen has a lot of
judgment issues it's it's not great when
someone else learns everything about
your town and judges you for now that's
the entire segment luck that's that's
the whole segment I'm excited yeah we're
gonna do we're gonna do stuff for you
next yeah telling you about my city yeah
the next part of our segment is I want
you to add ed that camera and I want you
you're the travel agent for Fort Myers
Florida Oh God I need you to pitch the
people that may be on the fence about
coming to Fort Myers and tell them why
they should come I mean if you're on the
fence fall the other way
you're good I mean there's an
International Airport oh yeah
but you still probably won't get a
direct flight you can't get a direct
flight to Germany woman they love that
they love for buyers in the winter for
Meijer if you don't know any better I'm
starting talking to you guys if you
don't know any better you can tolerate
it it's just like you know if you grow
up like if you're planning to come to
Fort Myers ask yourself something is
there somewhere else I can floor to
everybody she mouthed that she didn't um
one is never wearing clothing in here
I'm doing the card thing come on did it
good on that other episode I liked it
they [ __ ] up my might yeah laughs and
then in Naples there's yeah how about in
Jupiter I've always wanted I've ever
been to Jupiter I know
except I mean I'm actually just a minute
very ambitious naming is City age right
after a goddamn play I just know it's
actually named after the Roman guy we'll
talk about this is another episode one
of our guests is that are you actually
trying to jump out of this Jupiter
conversation to make sure it's fresh and
another time it was a Jody the material
I don't want to waste us no it's named
the Roman guide for the Roman version of
Greek Zeus is Jupiter that's what it's
named after the Roman juice like that
name Chris does all of our research
everybody and that's what I really like
that
Lachlan thought you were from Vancouver
yeah British Columbia my man I am let's
see what we got here it is the 10th
cleanest city 10 the world cleanest we
got to tidy it up Vancouver up man 10
could be 9 by next year also home the
world's largest swimming pool the
world's largest swimming the world's
largest swimming Hoover this is news to
me yeah I got Canadians all gonna talk
to our research swimming pool you've
been in the swimming pool dude I just
went to the swimming pool all the
swimming pool well it's it's where they
the Olympic I had to go the bathroom
I drew the bathroom and I was driving
and I found this not a good start so big
bathroom signs should be out on the
outside of all buildings agreed don't
you think there's like from the street
where you can drive by and see the
bathrooms anyway that's neither here nor
there
yeah but I'm familiar this is a pool
that was built for the Olympics I'm
assuming I don't know talk to our
research man right here who is this
built for Emily hitting a bomb right now
for the Olympic Village and all that so
that's the one I went in and it was
brand-new I'd never skated before since
I moved it pristine its brand new these
are pictures that I saw of it because I
looked it up after I read that and I
mean it's just so [ __ ] big and blue I
mean it looks like you gonna die from
like an airplane into it and like in
land safely you know I have a joke that
that professional swimming is the
hardest sport because it's the only
sport where you have no idea how you're
doing while you're doing it head down go
just swimming and hoping and then touch
the end of the pool and some guy you've
never met goes you a fifth
when we watch the race I couldn't see
anything I was flashing you were doing
good you were a swimmer people say I
should have been a swimmer I have a sore
spot
yeah and I'm always like that just
sounds daddy 11 feet tall I mean I think
you would give you an event alabaster 11
feet tall alabaster tall where do you
find out no so we have to drink six
times we're real loose around here with
the rules so you know alabaster is a
much more uncommon word I leave the
words why it's never alabaster right
okay right because if it was alabaster
we'd never say it tall that's not true
God really want to top ants out of my
kitchen alabaster yes wait was it not
tall respect the game all right
this is a weird one the sushi California
roll was actually invented in Vancouver
it's crazy
why why would that be imitation crab man
is that what it is we do a validation
imitation crab in Vancouver you know the
imitation crab is just a fish that sits
at really low at the seat and then when
other fish come around the corner he
comes out and goes who am i doing no
killer I've know it's weird
oh [ __ ] that kills me you put California
next anything it just fresh that's
California so it's nets if I throw it's
like the avocado thing to what Santa Fe
what's anything with Santa Fe
oh it is spicy mayo corn tortillas
I see mayo there it is half a what would
be like the Vancouver roll our salmon
Falls and oh this is Salmons big yeah
okay no farm salmon by the way don't eat
farm salmon why not good
nothing's good for you drinking a
Heineken nothing's good for I mean I
think the farm Salmons worse than the
Heineken baby huh
I think the salmon farm Sam is worse
because it has bacteria in it
right and you know that [ __ ] you farm
salmon you know right yeah get the wild
stuff get the stuff get that [ __ ] while
in the crazy videos here to see those
salmon gone wild no going against the
stream just partying fighting the Bears
just getting into it trying to eat the
bear that's when should we the bear
standing in a river and just trying to
jump to its teammates and that bears a
video game villain it's like we have to
jump to the next stream it's the big
boss alright Lockwood why why are we
going why are we going to Vancouver guys
Telstra didn't have to go to the Hoover
it is the most beautiful city in the
world
ooh and you can swim and ski in the same
day Wow Coover if you want to that's
[ __ ] a man can go for a bicycle ride
around the whole city along the seawall
it's beautiful one time I went around a
seawall and right in front of me right
in the path the size of the boardwalk at
the beach was a full-sized bald eagle
with a salmon on it his towns just
eating it [ __ ] just and everyone just
stopped and we all just watch this
family all right sorry it's right in the
backswing of this lovely story about a
bald eagle in the wild hunting a wild
salmon yeah Barney just kept coming out
that's true that does do that when you
suck on it anyway where was I [ __ ]
find out where I was and it's where you
should be in Vancouver BC Canada and
while you're at it hop on a ferry and
check out our capital Victoria beautiful
city cobblestone roads and goat on a
whale-watching tour get to see the
whales [ __ ] I want to go to
way like a subway I guess one of the
cleanest is why you're not here we are
on another sub well oh but see only the
10th cleanest and the warrior work on
that that's not pretty goddamn good
10:00 tomorrow a lot of place how many
cities in the wall there the thousands
that's pretty good as it says yeah we
can do better
damn these guys top ten top ten hey
that's hometown harassment all right
Chris where we going next man ah the
next game coming up is on two trues
alive why don't you oh yeah all right so
check it out each of us is going to say
two truths two facts that are about
themselves and then a third fact that is
a lie and then the panel is trying to
figure out which of those is a lot and
then you get a guess if your guess is
wrong you drink resmoke who's starting
to stop fizzle you feel good yeah let's
do those facts okay I was conceived in
Ohio okay I've been in a high-speed car
chase with the police officer holy [ __ ]
and I'm a malaria survivor whoa [ __ ]
okay malaria survivor but see Ike the
high-speed chase sounds crazy but feel
like with this game sometimes to trick
right right Rick
sometimes you go with like a boreal
right that's conceived in Ohio conceived
in Ohio right I take nine months to get
to Fort Myers it smell bad math here oh
you got her laughing so that mean that
that's a that's a tell of a lie she's
also buzzed out of my head right now
he's probably what happened you know
that's okay yeah just just yet you don't
even have to wave keys just wings to say
hello I honestly believe that you were
in a high-speed chase because I think
you're the kind of person so Chris's
vote is high spotless and I say the
truth is I so revealing it so what do
you what do you what do you feel ace
which one of you which one are you
feeling I'm thinking I'm just gonna take
the third
I'm gonna say that she threw the fake
one is right in the middle I'm gonna say
that she was never in a high-speed chase
you're both taking high-speed chase as
the fake I don't see her doing anything
hi I'm gonna take I'm gonna take malaria
survivor visit I was actually conceived
in Kentucky did you know you were being
chased yes we were actually running well
I wasn't driving but I was telling the
poor driver just speed up speed up me
escape it'll be fine yeah just horrible
influence and how are you 17
okay so you didn't get really in trouble
no he was like you'll never give him to
college I'm like you got to college so
then I'm in malaria huh yeah and I got
malaria and India got it yeah okay and
that's it
it just it always stays with you now
emotionally or is that true emotion do
you feel like yeah course you do today
we have a cut relationship now okay I
have a complicated area that's hilarious
how did you get my mosquito burn oh man
that's how people get it that's the
weird thing like you know there's you in
Florida I mean we've all you're gonna
broil for 40 here you see mosquitoes the
size before quarter land on you just go
yeah your slap one there just blood all
over your leg all of a sudden
oh yeah I don't even get a malaria in
America anymore didn't I get alright
even and we've taken a turn Chris why
don't you tell us some lies the truths
about yourself okay you guys ready yeah
yeah okay I was involved and an arms
deal when I was 25 I sold guns I have
won $10,000 on a game show and I have
lost over a hundred and sixty pounds of
my entire life
now now we got a lot of things going on
I know Chris somebody well yeah he said
arms deal yeah involved in arms deal I
know Chris for a very long time and he
has been involved with a lot of illegal
activity yeah but I also I mean it's
just I also know he's been on game shows
before okay okay uh what are you guys
feeling you got any ideas running around
your head yeah they're all so well I was
there also believable deal thing illegal
activity that's just that's just a part
of growing up in Florida right yes
exactly
yeah just yours so I think that's very
possible
we just someone just left Rachel left
Rachel left guys and now here we are
right just watch I know it's okay what
are you so let's get our guesses out
Lachlan
I'm gonna say that you you never won
$10,000 okay that's prison oh [ __ ] what
was the last one wait I've lost a total
of 160 pounds my life so you could just
switch the number it could actually be
like 162 and then that's what makes
that's tricky but it's strategy so I I
don't know like that because that's what
your strategy strategy changes a little
but it is a tragedy strategy trajan
either try strategy okay I'm gonna go
it's tragic you're doing the way yeah I
want to go with the weight going the way
because I'll take the third yeah members
take the guns okay
take the guns you don't believe that I
won money you know believe that I lost
the way and you don't believe that I I
know you sold so many drugs but I don't
think you sold any weapons ah
the lie was the gun all right take a
drink I won $10,000 on celebrity name
game and I've legit lost probably more
than a hundred sixty pounds but that's
not 160 that's but Chris is a man yeah
yeah
Lachlan you got something you got some
bud I was inspired to start performing
stand-up comedy from watching Star Trek
The Next Generation I've been to prison
before I've been to jail for a parking
ticket and I love to read I'm gonna jump
right out of the gate and say that it's
reading what I'm gonna take reading as
the law I look I don't look like a
reader oh it's not that I just don't
think anybody reads anymore oh man
reading I feel like I've been taking the
third every time I'm gonna jump out and
pick one I'm gonna say that Lachlan does
not love to read read books guys no I
think it's the first one I think you're
into you were not inspired to watch him
you don't think you know the first
wasn't right you think that he doesn't
like start the timing doesn't match up
because when next Jim was on look you
don't stand up at that point wait read
books generation is [ __ ] we do it open
them okay well one the second one was
not reading was a second oh boy giver
you know the worst thing that say to
someone when they're reading what are
you reading he's really selling this
reading thing guys thank God it was a
[ __ ] reading choosing reading as well
yeah what's the like I don't read
I want to I just can't open it folks on
tape and they I'm still gonna take a
drink that's hilarious but I yeah there
was an episode of Star Trek next
generation when I was a kid and data
who's the Android decides to turn the
holodeck into a stand-up comedy club
that is a [ __ ] great episode yeah
remember that episode and that I was
watching evening at the improv and then
that was more mainstream than any
evening The Improv and seeing stand-up
comedy for the first time on Main Street
TV I made the jump that that is actually
a success and opportunity it's it's it's
more see you can be successful and you
can be like data and everybody wants to
be like data that's my opinion
I love Star Trek me too [ __ ] yeah and
you thought he wasn't into alright
alright so I gotta do my my three in
high school I played baseball and
football I in college I wrecked my car
into a six trees I totaled it completely
totaled it and I have had a threesome
the third ones just sand in the eyes I
believe it he's a dirty [ __ ] threesome
is him and another girl quick what did
you say
I already know my pick because I know
him well enough I think I know there's
no the answers I think yeah
you think so so you don't want to reveal
things to the rest yeah can I go and
make my decision good I know you played
football but you've never once mentioned
playing baseball so I think this is a
half tiered lie but it still makes it a
line nonetheless good I don't even know
if that's true but it sounds so [ __ ]
true oma calvin smith he nailed you too
yeah I'm gonna say you never crashed
your car into a tree just because you
blew through that second one yeah I'm
gonna say the tree thing too
that's a lot of [ __ ] trees and you're
you know you're still here it's
absolutely that I did not play baseball
in high school his [ __ ] car and a
bunch of trees they found him half naked
he's gonna find the car yeah that's my
car into into a group of trees in a
blackout I wandered off from the car I
woke up without pants on in the middle
of a field didn't know where I was
didn't know how I got there and then
they found my car like two weeks later
and then I had to go there with my
ex-girlfriend now and my mother and pick
the car up and it was completely wrecked
and I just gathered my things out of it
and then I had the worst car ride back
to my house with them in the front seat
crying and yelling at me calling me an
idiot over and over again oh yeah with
the karmis me he described the car being
smashed up I should be dead you had a
bit of ejected I think I think I I think
what happened is is that did you wreck
the car do you think that and then oh no
no I wrecked it got out of it then the
trees fell on it oh yeah yeah so I you
know I stumbled out at the right time I
timed it well timed it well I would not
abate not a baseball guy and then I've
done just a lot of drugs so you know
threesomes happen yeah I'm just walking
around with two other dudes I'll wrap up
this segment hey how's it going
Instagram everybody give it a thumbs up
over here
hi are we video are we just talking to
it all right look don't freeze no no no
will keep the burp let's move on from
this but what do we got over here this
are our fun segments waste yeah oh my
god this is our favorite thing monkey
foods are just part of getting [ __ ] up
and what we do is we make go ahead yeah
I like like like the edamame do you have
this edamame or the oh no it's gonna be
oh no look at who your hosts are but
yeah yeah
organic celery Garrus chopped up
welcome to say what we like to call
wasting
[Music]
hey guys I hope you enjoyed watching us
make this delicious treat
now we're gonna dive into a gang let's
get all the glasses out of the way and
indulge in these life-size of Bagel
Bites Chris what was the nickname we
gave this I forget actually we got it
somebody gave it a nickname all right
yeah big Bagel Bites all right I'm gonna
dive into this everybody gonna get in it
all right help yourself so yeah if you
can see if you open it up there's like
mozzarella cheese the pepperoni it's
gonna be delicious
all right oh be great with something
like quinoa pesto well pretty damn good
George Harrison old George Harrison
young young my sweet lord George
Harrison used to oh they look good too
though it's good don't you hate when you
don't watch the cooking show and they
start saying yeah before the yeah yeah
wait oh my god that's really good again
I feel like everything I feel like I
always want to use the word decadent
whenever I'm describing any of the
things we're making you know we had a
different episode we made a thing that
was like a pizza burrito we essentially
took a frozen pizza and then filled it
with pepperoni and mozzarella cheese and
made like a cow's Oh
out of it this is reminiscent of it but
it's not and this I said reminiscent it
reminds me sorter of it but at the same
time it has it's a different that's
subtle no shuttle no other other things
it's a bagel with a bunch of pepperonis
on it this is the [ __ ] that we look in
your fridge and I got peppers I got
bagels exactly super easy to make and if
I turn on it
toast the bagel before mm-hmm do that
next time
so were these not toasted I feel like
you have heated by what breath put it on
the microwave and then they press 3 no I
feel like I would have enjoyed this a
lot more if I didn't accidentally walk
in on him in the kitchen how many day
cleanse you have to go on that you eat
this well I'm definitely gonna have to
get the recipe from somebody I got we
got it we got you bud
it's basically it's a you stab it with
the cheese buckle have it as many times
as you can
well guys it's still delicious and I
think that's what really I ripped into
mine and I asked me to finish it fine I
will
mmm I think
oh yeah the whole route all right my
favorite segments up next oh we're doing
it yes all right
we got clear out this we're gonna jump
in to be your own bartender one more
bite we'll get it enjoy yourself so it
is um they're gonna give us a name of a
beverage we're all gonna try and make it
with the best of our abilities they're
gonna give us like a little hint
everybody trying to make the drink and
then I'm gonna taste all of them and I'm
gonna pick a favorite they say the best
made drink hat and then we'll also find
out who made it the closest make sense
yes what I have done okay you get some
of these other okay you guys are gonna
be bartenders write your name bartender
BYOB like a professionally other that's
anyone ever had to know oh yeah do you a
bartender training I do oh [ __ ] yeah
everybody's in trouble upon a lot of
time with house ten years of my life get
some ice and all these cups yeah so
we're gonna be give up we're gonna give
me given a minute enjoying it but I just
was gonna mix ology parts fun I mean
that's what I think the true sign of a
real bartender is anybody make aromatize
yeah can I have a glass too as well
yes yes I'll pass them down and then
quicks let's hear that that drink name
in our glue and guys sorry good today's
cocktails a tequila sunrise sunrise
which gained notoriety after Mick Jagger
began drinking it and the Rolling Stones
dubbed their 1972 tour the cocaine and
tequila sunrise tour they called it that
that's pretty awesome
wait no no it's a minute and a half so
we have our clue we know I mean the name
has it in it so we have a minute and a
half
gang so I know we're all gonna be diving
for that tequila and we'll start that
minute and a half right now their latest
tour is called kids how about no it's to
embed before ninth or all right guys
second shows at 12:15 I'll be making it
however we want it yeah also realize I
have making it too really yeah
everyone's make now realize I have to
drink it so if you feel like making a
great drink that's not that I will have
it or if you feel like making a terrible
drink that you know I have to drink
that's also fun
I feel like Lachlan could probably make
a very bad cocktail if he chose to would
the bartending mate Chris you wanna hand
me that tequila we're running out of
time quickly how much time you have a
minute and a half we're all in trouble
we started oh man Lachlan already got
the shakedown this is what's up
I'm barracks that Chris is won every
single episode so far he's three and OH
so I'm pumped about second 30 seconds K
where is Wade looking for bud I'm
looking for the grenadine hernia oh
right there but thirty seconds there's
gonna be a buzzer responsible JCI man
just what you like it we're done guys I
just want to eat orange you guys start
stick I don't have a stir stick that's
okay
it's ready it's ready it's ready okay
let's uh let's let's bring them all out
front here let the camera get a gander
oh my oh me oh me oh gosh I'm very
excited about drinking Laughlin's drink
Jesus Christ I want to okay so let's
start cope explain your beverage and
then try yours I you know I knew what a
teal sunrise was I want to do mine a
little bit more heavy grenadine so
that's what's got the redder cut it
looks like you just poured grenadine
into a glass there's tequila and a
little bit of Oh Jack I think you're
gonna like it
I also lift the rim this is tequila with
over the line you like better
I heard lick the rim this looks like
it's all grenadine and I don't know if
I'm gonna enjoy it
Jesus that's just grenadine it's just a
mouthful of grenadine
it literally has a soup it's like clam
chowder take another sip to punish
myself it's so syrupy that's that hobo
fuel right there this if a [ __ ]
homeless man drank this he would
literally be driving around murdery
waking me up all night
oh good god Lachlan oh my you want my
drink dude yes explain it what was your
technique what did you go with like I
made you a tequila sunrise cheating
bartender oh my god it looks fantastic
the layers anybody looking at the layers
on this [ __ ] thing is gorgeous it's
gorgeous
normally stir it up a little but I think
it's a tequila sunrise Jesus Christ it's
perfection thanks buddy um Timmy tough
to beat can I try it yeah absolutely I
just want everyone oh oh please lot
gonna take a sip of his you didn't like
the rim right
no he licked it with a lime
that's fantastic a lot sweeter but I get
I get it he looks like he's a sweet
tooth yeah I do have a sweet tooth I
think it's as good as I thought it was
No
yeah hold that up go ahead describe your
penguin it's just a shitload of tequila
and orange juice just shit-ton it's a
kid I like the orange orange yeah they
did a garnish I don't you know oh you
know what just I'm gonna I'm gonna use
the garnish I think that's what drinks
are forged dive that in there
taste basically like a screwdriver yeah
what tequila not bad not bad
JC made us I absolutely drink one I made
one myself who judges yours
you can judge my and I'm gonna sip it
anyway it is a I did tequila
cranberry orange juice and a splash of
soda water
that sounds very lovely I did add some
soda water too
I should have added more soda water he's
pretty good pretty good now what are
they also luckily just say the
ingredients because you're gonna be
right
the ingredients are tequila orange juice
and grenadine yeah there it is and are
those the in fact the ingredients it
says it served unmixed to preserve the
color of each layer with tequila ven
oranges and then grenadine show that
show that where's that Lachlan drink
hold that up that does Aquila sunrise
friends I like that you're saying that
you enjoyed my best is there a garnish
on that I think there can be if you want
there to be as a cherry inside it I've
always whoa see Lachlan you're the first
bartender we've had on I think that's a
my vote 100%
Lachlan won something made made the made
the beverage correctly everybody that's
your your you guys are guilt Ford's your
your your your prizes I'm going to drink
the entire drink dude history could to
your drinks really I know I like it yeah
Cheers
you drink mine let's stick to beer
Christy you know where we go to the dark
side cheers gang hey I do I say thank
you guys so much for coming out of the
show yeah I've been impaired
Yeah right real quick where could we
have worked we find you guys visit us on
e fi z or everything's at visit us on e
fi za a Dasani do sa and i so what are
we right now so you'll be able to
where's where's he so mean
we're sorry where's the reading gonna
appear and I can point to it you just go
to just point everywhere Lachlan
Patterson calm Lachlan Patterson calm
and then write Lachlan Patterson there
and there Lachlan Patterson you just go
right down to come and go there and you
can check me out at Instagram at lock
jaw at Instagram and as always you can
find me on Twitter at JC stand up on
Instagram at JC comedian and Chris cope
but you can find me in Twitter on car
twitter.com and look first bucket name
everybody's cub comedy for Instagram and
everything else my website and Twitter
thank you guys so much for coming in and
enjoying another episode of impaired
give it up one more time for visit us on
easy have a nice day
[Applause]
[Music]